لا اله الا الله الان جنازه الشهداء تصل
هنا الى احد منازلهم كما نرى هؤلاء
الشهداء هم اربع اخوه سيودع عائلتهم
تحديدا سيودع الام التي فقدت في ذات
الدقيقه اربعه من
ابنائها يسج على الارض
الان هؤلاء الاربعه هم من اصل سته شهداء
قتلهم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال
صاروخ اطلق عليهم من خلال طائره مسيره
عندما يعرف
بمثلث الشهداء الواقع بين جنين
وا جنوب مدينه جنين ايضا عند
بلده قباطيه كما نرى يعني حاله من الغضب
حاله من الحزن في كل في كل مكان نتيجه هذه
الصدمه باستهداف الشه هداء بهذه الطريقه
رغم انهم كانوا تماما بعيدين عن موقع
تفجير العبوات الناسفه في الاليات
العسكريه في حي الجابريات المطل على مخيم
جنين ما تم في تفجير العبوات هو ما كنا قد
نقلناه منذ ساعات منتصف الليل تفجير عبوات
باليات عسكريه ادت الى اعطاب عدد من
الاليات العسكر هي ادت الى
[موسيقى]
م
كما كما نستمع الى اصوات اطلاق الرصاص هذا
الرصاص الذي يطلقه المقاومون الفلسطينيون
لاكثر من سبب الاول هو حدادا على الواح
شهداء جنين هؤلاء الشهداء الذين نراهم
امامنا الان والعائله تحاول وداعهم كما
نرى الام التي لا تعرف من تقبل اي ابن من
الاربعه ستقبله
اولا الاربعه يعني واحد منهم هو هزاع كان
يفترض ان يكون ساعات صباح هذا اليوم في
المستشفى يتلقى العلاج بسبب مرض الكلى
الذي يعاني منه وهذا ما يفند روايه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بانهم ان كانوا قد
يشكلون خطر على جنود الاحتلال ال اسرائيلي
المشهد يتحدث عن نفسه سفيان نتيجه ما يحدث
هنا ولكن بالطبع ايضا اطلاق الرصاص هو
حدادا على ارواح شهداء جنين حدادا على
ارواح شهداء قطاع غزه ام الشهداء الاربعه
كنا قد قابلناها في ساعات الصباح الاولى
في المستشفى وقالت ابنائي ليسوا اغلى من
شهداء
غزه كما نستمع
كما نستمع للتكبيرات
ونستمع يضا اصوات رصاص المقاومين الجميع
يحاول وداع الشهداء في ظل
هذه الصدمه الفاجعه
للاهالي الذين يجدون ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قتلت هؤلاء الشهداء انتقاما
بعد تفجير العبوات الناسفه في على الاقل
اليه عسكريه واحده ادت الى مقتل مجنده
اسرائيليه من الوحدات الخاصه في حرس
الحدود التابعه لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين احدهم وصفت حالته بال
الخطيره
جدا سيشيع الشهداء من هنا بالطبع الى
مقبره الشهداء المعروف مثلث الشهداء بانه
على مقبره شهداء الجيش العراق الذي
كان يقاتل هنا في عام النكبه وبالتالي هم
يرون ان دماء الشهداء كلها تتجمع هنا
المشاهد يعني حقيقه نعم تتحدث عن نفسها في
ظل هذا الوضع كما قلت طبعا جفارا يعني
الصور تتحدث عن نفسها لذلك لن اضيف شيئا
جيفارا البديري اذا كنت معنا من جنين شكرا
جزيلا لك